one of the stars of the Cowboys
performance last night on defense their
great linebacker Jaylon Smith joining us
on the program after shutting down the
Saints Jalen how surprised are you and
how well that defense played last night
not surprised thankful put a lot of work
and as far as preparation getting ready
to go against you know Hall of Fame
quarterback and we were locked in on all
cylinders we executed did you just wake
up again did you just wake up about an
hour ago
okay that's not bad what time do you go
to bed again what time did you go to bed
you know the game the game ended around
11 o'clock so I played with the bed ball
how do you calm down after a game like
that the reality of it is you gotta
celebrate you know get the win you
celebrate me you move on because it's
all about the next day the next play
okay what was this scouting report on
the Saints yeah they average about 40
points a game so need he don't make you
pay for you know our focus was to
execute that's something that we were
able to get down last night did you talk
to Drew Brees at all during the game
after the game you know how do you feel
about your Irish this year
you you know but I always think of that
Fiesta Bowl that you played and you
wanted to play and you said you had no
regrets and you had that devastating
injury which makes what you've
accomplished after that even more
amazing but you look back on that Fiesta
Bowl and have any second thoughts at all
no no we look at that game
you know for one on the in competitor
the captain of team first Ohio State
where my brothers in the college and
also it was about 13 projected
first-round draft picks playing in that
game you know playing against Ezekiel
Elliott and you know Taylor deck Eli
Apple Michael Thomas will fall these
high-powered
I don't know if you think you're gonna
get fine for the hit on Alvin Kamara how
would you describe that though if the
Commissioner reached out to you and said
because it looked like it was helmet to
helmet but I don't know about the intent
with that so how would you describe that
hit on Alvin Camaro everything you might
be doing down yeah you know as I went to
hit him he moved his head and you know
that's kind of where the code where the
collision happens but yeah there was no
intention you know do you think do you
think it's Super Bowl or bust for this
team now I saw the headline in the
Dallas Morning News but you as players
do you feel like it's Super Bowl or
nothing
no no we gotta focus on you gotta focus
on controlling we can control you know
that's too often to go you know we
wanted win the Superbowl book it doesn't
happen overnight
yeah really understand the process and I
respect the one game at a time and
that's the that's the best approach here
it's just now you're gonna have to
temper these expectations that the fans
the media the analysts
everybody is gonna now go hey you shut
down the Saints why can't we go to the
Super Bowl
exactly I mean that's that's good our
minds that somebody what it's just about
you know really about displaying that
you know on the field on Sundays on
Thursdays on Monday whatever plan you
know displaying what we're capable to do
that last night universe you know the
very high-powered you know offenses and
team last night so we have to carry this
like I said enjoyed this victory you
know but then move on we took a very
unscientific poll and we voted you best
arms in the NFL it was just you it was
just you Jim there were no other
candidates so we voted you best arms in
the NFL congratulations
there'll be an award coming your way but
we want to know okay my guys who work
with me we were trying to do over/under
how much you can bench one rep okay okay
let's go around the room here how
probably will start with you on what you
think Jalen can bench one rep 510 510
Seton for 7475 McLovin he's got long
arms though weighed 328 320 and who says
328 okay Fritzi I'm gonna say four for
them
I think I like the chili Jalen warms up
to 328 okay one rep Jaylon Smith I'm
going 524 90 all right okay I went over
who won I went over I had 475 well then
I think you know what it's a Notre Dame
fan sheen O'Connor
the Dumber hey Jalen congratulations and
it's been a bigger picture great success
story with what you've done and you know
good luck the rest of the season
man I appreciate you guys having me on
the show
you know everything that I've done
that's run with the clear eye view you
know a focus persons determine belief in
our dreams you know you know this
platform is so unique you know you get
this in a cereal story and you can
really you know people couldn't
understand you know your purpose beyond
athletics so this route is really not
thank you thank you Jalen that's a
Jaylon Smith he warms up to 328 pounds
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]